welcome to this DW business special
asking what the end of zero covid means
for China's economy
beijing's rigid approach to preventing
the spread of coronavirus left Chinese
citizens under the strictest conditions
on the planet for many months after much
of the world had opened up again
domestic frustration came to a head with
rare protests against the government of
President Xi Jinping adding to the
pressure caused by a weakening economy
within a matter of days came an
announcement that restrictions were
loosening and now it appears zero covid
has been all but dropped
but to discuss the causes and
consequences of that I'm joined in the
studio by DW's resident China water
Clifford [ __ ] and Clifford there's a lot
to talk about here isn't there there is
I think we're going to make a bold claim
today and say the 2023 is going to be
the year that China doubles down on the
economy and tries to put covert in the
rear view mirror but I think it's a road
map that's going to be very complex
well stay with us and we'll try and
navigate that but um also joining us on
the line is Marina rudyak who is a
specialist on China from the University
of Heidelberg Marina
um actually let's go straight in on this
how significant is the shift in policy
that we've seen from Beijing just over
the last week
well the shift is very significant also
the speed at which at which it happened
I mean if you think during the 20th
party Congress I think no one of us
would have expected that the government
will shift the covet policy so quick
and actually I want to just get an idea
of what is like in China now
particularly in comparison with how it
was so how has life suddenly changed for
people in China well Fabian kretchma is
a journalist in Beijing and he gave us
this update this week
now the new rules are implemented
Nationwide and they are really very
remarkable when you have mild symptoms
and are infected now you can cue them
out in your own home that's a huge
change before just some days ago we were
basically transferred to uh quarantine
centers also the lockdowns have been
suspended the city-wide testing so that
is a huge relief for many people for
many residents why because it brings a
lot of you know predictability uh into
your everyday life and of course the
fear of um yeah getting transferred to a
quarantine Center is over also the fear
of lockdowns is basically over and also
the daily hassle of waiting in front of
a PCR test station is over
um so I think it's really a big game
changer
Big Game Changer Fabian Christmas says
there Marina red Jack I mean you said
that this is such a a big change that
seemed almost impossible when we were
back at the the Party Conference not
that long ago why such a sudden change
well there has been a lot of
speculations that the party was looking
for a way out because of The Economic
Consequences but um despite all the
protests that we have witnessed we
should not forget that there is also a
very strong Pro zero covet Lobby on the
Chinese internet which is much more
outspoken than the protesters so while
the party was looking for a way out
there was a lot of fear of backlash what
happens if the numbers go up now they
can say well it's the citizens that
wanted uh an end of the zero Corvette
policy and they can shift the
responsibility in particular to the
students who protested against the zero
corporate policy if the numbers go up
now that's interesting isn't it the idea
of Shifting the blame um Clifford coonan
in the studio with me here this does not
come without its risks to the Chinese
population does it this loosening of the
the covered rules yeah I think it's like
Marina was saying um uh Xi Jinping has
as you know said at the party Congress
that you know that they were going to
take one course indeed he said they're
going to annihilate covert they haven't
done it and um instead what they've done
is that they've um following these
protests they've they've reviewed the
covert the zero covert policy uh quite
dramatically I don't think it was the
protests that actually drove it myself I
think is probably more like that this
was in train anyway because the economy
has been so flagging of late that that
China really needs it
um what Marina was saying there she made
it almost seem as though this were The
Apprentice provided an opportunity for
this change in policy and something for
it to be attributed to I think so yeah I
don't think there was a Eureka moment I
think definitely this was going on for a
while there was a they were looking
around for options there's a lot of
reasons a lot of things aren't in place
I mean it's still winter and getting rid
of zero covert policy in the middle of
winter when respiratory diseases are at
their worst you know we've had lots of
reports one model I was looking at was
saying that there could be a million
deaths you know from wigram um advisors
had these this modeling for that so
there's some pretty shocking figures out
there and we've seen things about people
queuing outside
um pharmacies and things like that so
there's a lot of there's a lot of um
challenges here what I want to get into
is whether or not this is a calculated
move by Beijing that sort of Trades off
the benefits of opening up the economy
again versus the potential uh
effects for for and potential deaths
indeed you know the effects for the
Chinese population now the announcement
of a looser approach to the pandemic
came at pretty much exactly the same
moment as Beijing released some dire
data on China's International Trade not
only did Imports for during November to
their lowest level since early 2020 so
the start of the pandemic but have a
look at this exports plummeted compared
with a year earlier see that down 8.7
percent compared with last November and
that was much more of a drop more than
double in fact than what most analysts
had been expecting Marina rudiak on that
and how much is this move by the
government about getting China's economy
back on track
well certainly economy plays a big role
because um as we know the contract
between the party and the people has
always been we make sure that you are
continuously better off economically and
you stay out of politics and this
contract is not working anymore in
particular not for the young people and
they were the ones who were protesting
on the streets and who are linking the
their protests against the zero covet
policy to a general discontact this
content with the party and its leaders
so the party I think finds itself
between between the Rock and the hard
place because on the one hand opening as
Clifford just said will mean that the
numbers will go up and that the virus
will spread in a largely unvaccinated
population especially among the elderly
but on the other hand
um there is a need to intervene with the
protests and to make sure that those who
are protesting against is the party and
who have linked their zero covet
protests to the protest against the
party that this does not become bigger
so the party needs to react and also
needs to to find ways to recreate this
balance that uh giving people what they
want economically because in the end
Chinese people want to be governed
properly and I think this is something
that has not received enough attention
in in the whole debate
Clifford coonan um that idea that I
floated that this was essentially a
decision to
put at risk the health of some Chinese
people in favor of the economy and
improving the economy is that an
exaggeration on my partner I think in
some ways
um there's sort of a parallel almost
with Britain with the way Boris Johnson
um when he they basically at a certain
point just said okay well we just have
to get rid of the countries did have to
make that decision it feels like a long
time ago now but a lot of them were were
essentially just saying well we'll
accept more cases
um for an improvement in our economy
yeah and I think I think a lot of it
isn't the fact that they're not just
going to blanket get rid of everything I
think you're going to have localized
measures in place um I was you know in
contact with someone in in China today
who's just arrived across the border uh
from Hong Kong and they're in they're uh
in a in a place they're they're being
held in quarantine just as they would
have been a week ago so this is very
selective I think but the narrative is
going to be about uh ending the zero
covert policy and very important what
we've just had was the meeting of the
pilot Bureau which is the one of the
main uh governing bodies within the
Communist party and they've decided that
fixing the economy is going to be the
focus of everything and that's going to
be a very important factor be because we
also coming up very soon we have the
economic work conference which is where
the Communist Party decides on
policies to to run the economy because
China is a centrally planned economy and
that meeting is coming up very soon and
I think seeing what come out of that
comes out of that is going to be really
interesting that's like you said at the
start of this program next year is going
to be all about getting the Chinese
economy back on track all right I think
so I think it has to be because we saw
the trade figures they're terrible and
um the economy uh the social contract
and that Marina was talking about if if
you don't if you don't provide economic
growth you you you don't get to rule
anymore Marina rudyak is this going to
make a difference to the economy and how
quickly is it going to make is it going
to make it quickly enough to alleviate
the uh the pressure on the the Communist
Party in Russia in in China to
um to confuse those two ideas I don't
know
um is it going to happen quickly enough
to alleviate that pressure on Beijing
well I don't think that we can expect a
quick recovery because I mean it will
take time for the economy to rebounce
um we should be clear that
um when China will start opening up uh
the numbers of uh covet infected people
will go up and we will probably see
something parallel to what we're seeing
now in Germany with
um not enough Personnel being in place
due to high sickness levels and we can
expect the same in China so the problem
will shift from from lockdowns to higher
uh covet infection numbers
um on the positive side
um it will it will be easier for for
international economic activities
um we are seeing now that it looks like
biotech will be recognized um as a legit
vaccine for foreigners in China
reciprocally now we saw Germany will be
recognizing synovac so at least for
companies it will be easier to send
their people to China but still I don't
think we can expect a quick rebound and
whether it's gonna be quick enough will
be the big question
Okay Marina Clifford more from you in a
second but um the biggest impact of
China's strict covid measures has been
felt by the people of China of course
themselves who have had three years of
having their movements restricted and
having to abide by stringent testing and
quarantining laws so what do they think
of this shift in approach well here's a
view of just a couple of people on the
streets of Beijing
if you're in one of the central
quarantine facilities there are serious
cases there you may end up more
seriously infected it would be better if
you quarantined at home I know someone
who's been positive for two days with
his friend and they're okay taking cold
medicine at home
to be honest I'm quite satisfied with
the new policy because it's impossible
to kill this virus completely maybe just
live with it and hope it will evolve
into the common flu
to our resident China Watcher Clifford
coonan on that uh they seem pretty
pleased there that things are loosening
up is there any chance of the
restrictions returning though
well I was just thinking about this on
Sunday 22nd of January's uh Lunar New
Year which is the one of the biggest
human migrations on the planet I think
the biggest human migration on the
planet uh when a lot of Chinese people
will be going home and I think a lot of
people are already home they have they
haven't returned to the cities but
you're still going to see a lot of
people huge movements within China and
that's a possible super spreader event
on a scale which I think the planet has
never seen yeah it's amazing right right
and so if that happens it could be a
disaster but then again it could be that
now that we have ways of treatment and
we have you know it may not be as as
Grim as it as it might have been but it
does there's ever every possibility that
the restrictions could return
Marina ridgeac if I could just crossed
you um did those protests show that
there has been a change in the
relationship between the Chinese people
and their government
well I think
um the question uh has to be answered
whether yes when it comes to the younger
population and probably know where it
comes to the older population I think
that
um with the people we've been seeing on
the streets were mostly young people it
was the young middle class we've seen
students in universities protesting and
this is the generation that has not
experienced the hardships their parents
have experienced their parents have seen
China becoming richer their lives
becoming richer and more stable these
young people are seeing prospects of
their economic uh Freedom economic
welfare and their personal development
shrinking continuously so for them
um the promise of you know party taking
care of them
um it has been really shattered and how
this will play out this will be a big
question I've been I've been hearing
from my students that they say now we
understand why the people in Hong Kong
were on on the streets and we feel sorry
that we didn't support them back then so
this is a shift that is happening within
the younger generation whether that will
be calls for real democracy not sure
first of all people want to be governed
in a proper way and the government to
abide by the laws but I think you know
this can be a spark of some bigger
change we have we will have to see how
this develops
well and on that note I think that's a
good place to leave it looking forward
to to the Future and what this might
bring so I'll say thank you to my guests
Marina rajak from Heidelberg University
thank you so much for joining us and
Clifford coonan as well our resident
China Watcher always here to help us out
on these issues now if you've enjoyed
this little chat there is plenty more
from dwu business here on the DW news
YouTube channel do check it out until
next time though take care